it's been the soul of FIFA this year
obviously we want to innovate across the
entire pitch we have tons of innovations
in our gameplay this year but we also
want to help you compete a higher level
and also give you new ways to play and
each of these massive pillars within the
game has been built with the millions of
FIFA fans out there in mind so let's go
to the pitch and see the most balanced
FIFA yet when playing the game you want
confidence in defense you want to be
able to defend with purpose and backbone
so in FIFA 16 all new defensive agility
gives you the mobility you need to track
skilled players especially when they're
on the break and teams really win when
they defend as a unit so this year
you'll have better defensive shape on
the pitch to help break down attacks and
counter-attack when you win the ball and
in the middle of the pitch you'll
control the midfield the battleground of
any great match interception
intelligence helps shut down options and
close dangerous passing channel and on
the counter passing with purpose lets
you play sharp passes to slice through
defenders it's now a more considered
build up through the midfield with more
options than ever before and in the
final third you want more moments of
magic more skills better dribbling also
you can create menacing attacks and
sometimes the best touch is the one that
you don't take so we've captured the
movement of today's best player to bring
you no touch dribbling free yourself
from the ball to buy time create
separation and blow by your defender
just as Messi does when he's at his best
it's near limitless creativity and
changes the game profoundly and when
you're in on goal clinical finishing
helps you create those wow moments only
FIFA can deliver from box to box from
sideline to sideline we're innovating
across literally every inch of the pitch
so you can play your way and for every
fan we're giving you the ability to
compete a higher level whether you're
new to FIFA or play every season FIFA
trainer will help dial up your game no
matter your level the controller
language you see here on screen will
change as you move around the pitch and
bring you options
or to help you play better defense make
better passes and hopefully score more
goals and this year finally we're giving
you an amazing new way to play for the
first time ever in the fifa franchise
women's teams are in the game we've been
working on this for years and it's at
the level of authenticity that FIFA's
known for thanks to our motion capture
technology and our body and facial
scanning and our gameplay engine and
physics engine give us the right
platform to build outplay specific
models and animations specific to the
best female athletes in the world
it's huge news for the franchise and
something myself and the FIFA team are
immensely proud of so a balanced
experience across the whole game
innovation across the entire peach
completes at a higher level and new ways
to play and that's just the start we
have news on the rest of the game
throughout the summer as we continue to
make FIFA 16 a beautiful experience and
finally I know it's something
forgettable I just want to remind you
that Pele was on stage with me about
three minutes ago how crazy was that but
now to commemorate this huge moment
along with Pele and our friend Leo Messi
we're dropping a special item into the
account of all our loyal FIFA 15
Ultimate Team players so go check it out
at the end of the press conference and
let's take a look at the beautiful game
in FIFA 16
the game played by the entire planet the
game that brings us together the game
made up of many faces but the beauty is
in the moments powerful
suspenseful stunning
spine tingle
but for hazmat guilty as a happy for as
much beauty as a experience I know I
have seen nothing yet
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but what is beauty if you cannot
experience it
FIFA 16